salutation tien ne cherchez pas à savoir
qui je suis car en fait je suis anonyme
non mais laisse tomber ça marche pas du
tout bon ok ah fait chier bon
sérieusement on rigole mais en fait si
ça continue on va pas rigoler longtemps
croyez-moi et en fait si on est là
aujourd'hui pour faire une vidéo tous en
commun c'est pour vous parler d'un sujet
qui craint vraiment et oui peut-être en
avez-vous déjà entendu parler ou pas car
il semble que cette loi n'intéresse pas
beaucoup Monsieur Pujadas ou monsieur
Pernau et pourtant elle est important
l'ACTA est déjà au portes du Parlement
européen initialement cette loi elle
avait été faite pour lutter contre la
contrefaçon c'est loouable mais ça a été
complètement dévoyé de plus aucun élu du
peuple n'a été impliqué dans sa
conception faut dire que c'est normal
elle a été écrite sous la dictée
d'intérêt privé qui s'accroche à un
modèle économique dépassé le plusist
dans tout ça c'est que personne parle de
je veux dire moi je suis pas trop les
informations en ce moment je sais pas on
parle de C espèce de concours là
élections présidentiell je crois ça
s'appelle et alors mais alors l'cta
c'est juste la loi la plus c'est la loi
qui nuit le plus à notre liberté sur
Internet de 2012 mais personne n'en
parle en effet il y a deux sortes de
lois les lois liberticides et les autres
et non content de nous empêcher de
partager ACTA va aussi nous empêcher de
créer puisque tout contenu présentant
une infraction au droit d'auteur sera
susceptible d'être supprimé quand à son
créateur bah pour lui ce sera l'amende
ou la prison dans ces conditions il nous
sera interdit de s'approprier et de
détourner les produits culturels et nous
redeviendrons tous de simples
consommateurs passifs et àone comme à la
bonne vieille époque de la télévision
vision avec une loi comme ça terminée
les tests de jeux vidéo les séries
abrégé les parodies à la con une grosse
partie de la création amateur du net
sera considéré comme illégal bah ouais
braquage viol 5 ans et toi moi je fais
des vidéos sur Internet et des fois
j'utilise des musiques dont j'ai pas les
droits tu es un malade tu me
dégoûtes alors que peut-on faire
aujourd'hui des associations défendent
vos droits et font pression sur les
politiques avec des moyens simples et
puissants mis à votre disposition il
s'agit de pétitions d'email à envoyé
rapprochez-vous d'association tes que
avaz.org et la Quadrature du Net et
agissez simplement pour préserver
l'Internet de la censure qui veut lui
être imposée est-ce que c'est utile oui
par exemple face au dernier
rassemblement l'Allemagne a fait machine
arrière et a suspendu son vote sur le
texte aux USA la réaction massive des
internautes a réussi à faire reculer les
deux projets de loi américaines SOPA et
PIPA qui elle aussi s'attaquer à liberté
individuelle alors si vous ne voulez pas
qu'Internet devienne un supermarché
Géant et si vous avez pas envie que
YouTube devienne une plateforme de vidéo
composée uniquement de vidéo de chat
allez visiter les liens en dessous et
informez-vous sur ce qui'est réellement
la loi ACTA ben moi je suis d'accord
avec eux les assurances aCTA c'est
vraiment des margoulins il parle pas des
Assurances a ça il parle du traité ACTA
B c'est des margoulins quand
même nous aCTA c'est une loi qui va nous
à poil
[Musique]